yeah hello and welcome to this video
unfortunately today our uploaded three
blitz videos that did not have any sound
and to make things worse
I had pre-scheduled roughly 30 videos
for the next couple of days like right
before my vacation I wanted to produce
something so they don't I need to record
daily while away so I could roughly 30
videos without any sound the reason is
the bloody Windows Update ok so what to
do with all the videos this is the
question that I'm actually asking you
now should I just release the 30 videos
as some sort of a bonus without sound I
mean it's a bit odd but I would yeah
record new ones but I just wonder should
I should should I just toss the 30
videos or should I upload them like in
one batch without sound and like market
no sound sorry guys it's a bonus what do
you think I should I just toss it it's
it's a bit I mean it's not the most fun
experience to notice that you've
recorded 30 videos basically for nothing
and now not for nothing but it's it's
kind of frustrating anyway so what
should I do
should i upload them should I ditch them
please give me your opinions thanks a
lot bye bye